your sense of humor is so distinct and
so your own I'm just curious where'd you
get your sense of humor from was it
someone in your family my mother was
very funny I mean I think my whole
family they're funny in their own ways
but she was she's funny she was funny in
her own way and she was in a really bad
car accident this is kind of the perfect
example maybe you won't think it's funny
but she broke like every bone in her how
old were you when this was when this
happened I did not exist okay all right
but well I didn't exist the car accident
I was not alive yet she broke every bone
in her body
nearly and they used little screws to
straighten out all of her broken toes
and when she got out of the hospital she
asked if she could keep those screws and
and then she started using them for
cocktail parties to put through olives
and she also used her vomit tray for
nuts and snacks
and people would come over this was now
when I was alive
as a child so people are having a drink
they're having a drink and they're like
oh Susie this is such a cute idea to put
a screw and they olive in the martini
what gave you that idea and she's like
oh those came out of my toes vomit tray
that the nuts were in
you